[Music]
this is star talk
i'm neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today we're going to
do cosmic queries with my co-host nadine
farsad negan welcome back to star talk
oh my god hello thank you so much for
having me neil hello
so you you
you you're getting around this first you
have this book what is it how to make
white people laugh what was the name of
that book incorrect it was it's called
how to make white people
that's right
that's cause you technically are not a
white person you're something else yes
i'm just like this uh bag of ethnic is
what i like to call myself oh ethnicity
yeah yeah so you're born
i'm one of the one of these nice
iranian-american muslims okay
looking at america and figuring it out
yeah yeah no don't even try because we
can't even figure it out i don't know um
and also your host uh wait let me let me
remember uh fake the nation oh my gosh
neil your memory is so good right now
no one's taking their vitamins yeah
let's fake the nation a political comedy
podcast which you have also been on i
have been on it and it's on uh siriusxm
if memory serves uh we actually just
moved over to headgum but we think very
fondly of those serious days yes okay
very good and i enjoyed my time on that
and i just know that i haven't gotten a
second invitation that's all but
that's okay i'll deal with it very
exclusive club neil and we'll get to you
when we get to you
and
today we have for cosmic queries uh one
of my colleagues and i love it when we
have one of my colleagues because
whatever astronomy i know we're bringing
them in because they know more of
whatever it is we're talking about so
they're like they're boosters for
anything i could possibly do in the show
and this is aomawa shields and i did i
please help me pronounce your first name
that's it
i get it i get a a b-plus at least for
that
it's been a delight uh we haven't i
haven't seen you in almost 15 years uh
great to have you on the program and to
learn that over that time you've become
an expert in the search
for
exoplanets and the possible signatures
of life this is
really hot stuff and anytime there's any
progress in that field i am glued to the
research papers just to to figure out
where you guys have coming from where
you are and where you're going and
we've got a cosmic queries focused on
that so i think we're all in on you
there so just let me get get a little
bit of your background here you're an
associate professor in the department of
physics and astronomy at uc irvine
very cool beautiful campus there by the
way and
uh you're specializing in earth-sized
planets orbiting low-mass stars
i think low-mass stars are like very
popular in the galaxy right
more low-mass stars than any other kind
of star so
you're hedging your bets there right
wait so if low mass stars were on tick
tock would they be the viral sensation
at 70
70 of all stars
okay
now i understand
that's how that's how they roll and we
will add to that the fact that before
she went on to get her phd in
astronomy she got a master's in fine
arts in acting
acting
acting
and so how do you combine acting in
modern astrophysics you can use that
theater background to help communicate
science and dad this is what
she's been doing and you've got a
website here it's called
risingstargirls.org
i love it uh it's promoting sort of
interest in science among girls of all
colors and all uh all stripes uh girls
have been sort of uh
under-represented over the decades uh
not only in astronomy but all sciences
and so this is this is wonderful and
it's great to have you here
oh
thank you so much neil for having me
here um it's really an honor and i'm i'm
excited to to hear the cosmic queries
and to talk about my background yeah and
and i and i'll i'll dip in to see how
your background can inform or enhance
what we know or what
education
uh steps you've taken over your career
because i'm very much interested in that
i i'm a big fan of the arts
or capital a so you know the painting
sculpting performing writing and to have
notice notice he did not say comedy
you need a really capital a for arts if
i'm gonna include comedy
how have your how has your website
worked
how does it work
uh mechanically that someone logs in and
then they see material there and and
take me through a a an encounter
that a girl might have with your website
so the rising star girls is a program
that i put together it's been about six
years now since it was officially a
thing i started back in grad school
doing outreach to middle school girls of
color and i would always have some kind
of interactive component i would bring
them to the planetarium at the
university of washington where i was a
phd student and i'd show them a
planetarium show and then we might do
some kind of a a project together like
making their own little planispheres uh
star charts that they could take with
them
and
sometimes i would do a theater game with
them and i found that they really
enjoyed that and i think part of that
was they
they knew they couldn't get it wrong
middle school is that age where girls
start to get quiet
they start to raise their hands less
often that's where you lose them that's
right that middle school oh my gosh
yeah they become more focused on on
their appearance and less focused on how
they think and feel about the world and
so that's the crucial age that's what
the literature says and and then of
course girls of color um have this
particular uh
this particular um
they're in jeopardy because on top of
the the age
group issue um they're also young women
of color and um there's just not any
role models or not many in stem for them
and so
um i thought you know how can i put my
theater background that i had
together with the astronomy background
and help these girls realize that there
is so much more to them than meets the
eye
and that what they think and feel about
the world and the universe is actually
not just important but critical
to their involvement in learning about
the universe we didn't just want to
pummel them with facts
they would have to regurgitate in class
we actually wanted to
help them to feel connected to the
universe and to that star or that galaxy
or that planet they were learning about
in hopes that if they felt connected for
example like by writing a poem about
that planet or that star or um drawing a
picture about an exoplanet that
could actually exist making up a name
for it making decisions about whether it
actually
had life or not
that they could look up in the sky and
say that's my star that's my galaxy i
wrote a poem about it i you know to take
actual ownership of what they were
learning and that that and hopes that
that would once they and you know
hopefully continue on in astronomy
that they would feel that connection and
that that connection would stay put once
the heavy math came in so that's been
well known if you name something it
becomes a little more personal
and i i'm omnivorous and so uh when i
buy a lobster and i'm about to cook it i
try to name it first
just so that i feel a little more deeply
for it when i plunge it headfirst into
the boiling water
so
but
exactly what i'm talking about this is
exactly it's the same thing
it's the same thing
no but nasa of course names all the
rovers and and there's a participatory
dimension to that that i think goes very
far
in the in educational circles but but
wait a minute if you thought of i've
read a little on your bio you thought of
making acting a career
but forces of the universe
i actually kind of sort of did for a
while descended upon you oh my gosh
so what i probably couldn't
yeah i mean i always had a day job um i
had you know i had started a phd program
right out of undergrad um
and i sort of did that because that's
what you did and i didn't really it
wasn't really a conscious choice
that phd program was in astrophysics and
i had started it did one year
but
i was incredibly divided i i am
i people would talk about what movie
they'd gone to see or the oscars that
were coming up and i was like oh you
know i would perk up then
and
um but like the problem sets and that
you know i was just i i wasn't i wasn't
focused we weren't feeling it weren't
feeling it yeah so and i didn't i looked
around and you know i did have an
african-american man who was my advisor
so there i wasn't the only
the only
person of color in the department but i
was the only student of color the only
woman of color
and i didn't see a lot of astronomers
around who
not only looked like i did but sort of
acted like i did like i had this thing
where i really liked
wearing makeup i liked fashion magazines
i liked um to wear nice clothes i
dressed pretty fashionably and i didn't
really see that as much of a
yes the opposite really is the opposite
just didn't really care about that i'm
thinking it's kind of the opposite
so there were all of these things like
and and
yeah
what you did was you you you had a
little checklist of all the things to
make sure you didn't belong
actually exactly and i was looking i was
looking i'm picturing you i'm picturing
like a devil devil wears prada
astrophysics
edition
[Music]
yeah and it was always like i was
building a case from the moment i got
there and everything was like yes oh
yeah check check check these are the
these are the reasons why i shouldn't be
here and
when the opportunity presented itself in
the form of a
stodgy white old male professor who said
consider other career options i i took
them up on it um
and so just to be clear it's not that
you intentionally did these things to be
different it's that these were part of
who you were
and that identity did not have receptors
in the environment where you were to get
your phd and so that mismatch
then sent you to an off ramp is that a
fair way to characterize it
i think that's fairly accurate i mean i
can't blame it all on
the outside forces there was a lot going
on internally that i take responsibility
for i think if i had known really really
known the way i did 11 years later what
i wanted to do there's nothing that
would have stopped me from doing it um
but i didn't i didn't know that then and
i was very sort of
um
on the edge of a precipice anything
could have anything could have tossed me
over and so i ended up going in the
other direction right so okay so you're
so you took this off ramp and now you're
a professional actor for a bid first
i had to go to school
and let me guess your parents love the
idea of you going into acting
well here's here's the odd thing about
it they're both performers
they're both they're both performers and
and have been their entire lives so
but the but the answer is still yes they
were like
um they didn't want that life for me
they were very excited about me having
what they considered a much more
dependable career as a scientist
although it's certainly as everyone
who's a scientist knows it's hard to get
a job in science after you get your phd
but plus if memory serves you also got
romantically involved with an actor so
this is like there was no one back
[Music]
okay
but they were like i think i think they
loved the idea of being able to say even
though they were performer performer
having a daughter they could say he was
an astrophysicist
was pretty awesome they gave me street
cred at the party yeah very good yeah
but i burst that bubble and was like i'm
going back into the family business so
to speak and i think that they were
certainly
fearful you know how she gonna make a
living and but they wanted me to be
happy above all else and so they
supported that and yeah i
i sort of during that first year in that
phd program i applied on the dl to mfa
acting programs i had done that during
senior year on the dl is on the down low
on the download excuse me okay
just have good get the lingo
okay okay
but and so i had applied to acting grad
schools
actually along with astrophysics grad
schools during um my last year at mit uh
in undergrad but i hadn't got i went for
the fences with those i applied to yale
uh the globe at uc san diego
and um nyu so famous acting places yes
yes and i hadn't gotten into those and i
was like but i did get into astrophysics
grad school so i i went so when the
second time around i when i was like i'm
gonna apply again i sort of spread the
net more widely and i rode these sort of
secret buses to chicago from madison
wisconsin on the deal
[Laughter]
and um applied and got into
the mfa program at ucla
and decided to defer from my phd
astrophysics program at wisconsin
madison and i moved out to la and and
started acting school there
and i mean
it's just you also seem like i mean
what it sounds like so far is that
you've been to a crap-ton of school
is that an accurate collecting degrees
yes
so now it's like there's a phd there's
an mfa and and i think you'd do the
terminal degree so you don't put the
scp up there okay but before we take a
break i just want to know who was it the
north star that called you back uh wha
what what cosmic force said
uh
or was it come back to us we watched it
was it
the whisper of the wind through the
trees in this in the in the moonless
cloudless night as the universe poured
from the sky back into your veins
it was
smog
[Laughter]
i handed you a poetic thing you could
have said yeah that was it and we could
have moved on
[Laughter]
being able i'm driving through the
streets of la to you know odd audition
after audition and these like cold
fluorescent look lit fluorescently lit
rooms casting rooms and
and having my like
day job at working for a cultural
non-profit and and
every once in a while my eyes like crane
up through the windshield and i try to
see through through the smog through the
clouds
and sometimes i'm able to see a couple
stars
and sometimes nothing
but like when i was able to see a couple
stars it sort of like shot me back in my
seat like oh that was another life
and then i pretend i hadn't seen it and
just get back to like driving in
gridlock and
you know trying to get to my job and
put my flyers for different cultural
programs around the city and
but i kept that kept happening and i
thought
someone asked me a friend asked me like
did you miss
astronomy because you could probably get
a better paying day job doing that than
your little
cultural arts non-profit or your temp
jobs i once pulled staples out of paper
for a year and a half for a
music publishing company that had to
have all of their contracts scanned
they had to have them all scanned so
they had they hired three temps to sit
in a room and pull staples out of you
can't scan documents that are stapled
together you just can't yeah you just
can't
that's great you know i just want to say
as a
still a comedian an actor i still go to
auditions and sometimes i look up into
the sky and then i think to myself like
i could really eat a burger right now so
very similar it's a different thing
and but i still like the fact that you
you had applied
to uh premier acting schools and they
rejected you so i guess i'll have to go
to astrophysics graduate school
i just love that
it reminds me there's a gary larson
comic where einstein was playing
basketball right and the caption is um
albert einstein was going to be a star
basketball player until an ankle injury
turned him to physics and then he became
oh my god anyway we gotta take a break
when we come back more with omawa
shields and her
the story of her life and we're gonna
bring in some cosmic queries that tap
her expertise on planets around other
stars and the possibility of life on
star talk
we're back star talk cosmic queries i
got my co-host nadine prasad always good
to have you here
oh so happy to be here yeah and we have
with us almoa shields a colleague of
mine at university of california irvine
and she specializes in
planets orbiting
stars
in the search for life
and to me that's the hottest topic in
all of science not just within
astrophysics and uh nagin you've
collected uh cosmic queries for her yes
yeah
yeah and i'm here to either just not say
anything or if
because this is all for you uh but if uh
if if there's something i think i can
contribute i i will but probably not so
let's jump right in
um well we um actually before we get
into some of the more sciency questions
jiraj petrovic on patreon um just asked
uh
he he wants to know he talked about alan
alda dedicating a lot of time and money
and effort into educating scientists
about how to communicate with the
general public and asked of you how has
your acting
training helped do you communicate with
your students and with the general
public about your research and
discoveries and has it helped any way in
getting funding for your research
i love that question
um thank you for asking it
you know when i first
came back to grad school so the second
time around i had it's been 11 years
between my phd program and astrophysics
the first one and the second one which i
started in the fall of 2009 and i had my
mfa in acting by that time
and so you're actually 70 years old
right
i'll give you the name of my
dermatologist
yes
i had a trifecta of issues that made for
like fertile soil for the imposter
syndrome to take root
i had i was an african-american female
in a field dominated by white men just
to be clear the absolute the imposter
syndrome is where you are actually
qualified to do what you're doing but
your confidence doesn't measure up to
that
and you're left uh uncomfortable in that
setting did i capture that right that's
right so i felt like at any at any
moment i was going to be found out for
the fraud that i was you know
african-american female
older returning students i was 34 years
old the second time around starting a
phd program with everyone else was
straight out of undergrad so they were
like 22 23. um and i was a classically
trained actor in an astronomy phd
program and that last part is why that's
the connection to this question because
i thought at first that i had to sort of
sweep
that like unseemly foray into the
humanities under the rug
people in the department were like they
thought it was really
cool lunchtime talk like oh you have
this mfa in acting and i was like yeah
yeah but i'm here for astronomy
um
i my very first journal club talk a
journal club talk is when
um for grad students usually you present
someone else's paper so a paper that
someone else has written about some
astronomical phenomenon
in like a 20-minute talk you kind of do
an overview of the paper maybe show a
few of the figures from the paper and
then
take questions
and my first talk the first one that i
had to give it was like i went
completely dear in the headlights
it wasn't the presentation part that
part i was fine with i i was a
classically trained actor i was used to
getting up in front of people and
talking but what i wasn't used to was
people talking back to me
asking me questions there's this thing
in the theater called the fourth wall
which is an invisible wall between all
of us performing up here on stage and
the audience and nobody breaks that
fourth wall unless they're invited
um like in some kind of call and
response so the fact that in a science
talk people can ask questions during a
talk after the talk even before the talk
wait nagin let me just clarify here
what she's saying is people are up in
your face
yeah so um
it's not just sitting back it's like
wait a minute is that
they're like coming at me like arrows
right academia this is what it sounds
like it sounds like a comedy club on a
saturday night at 10 p.m where you're
got a lot of drunk hecklers that's what
academia is sounding like to me right
now is that accurate is it mine is the
alcohol
were you essentially being heckled by uh
astrophysicist
that's how i took it that's how i took
it i had no i see and this is like i i
came so far over the course of that five
years because now what i see a science
talk is is it's a conversation it's a
discussion people ask you questions
because they actually care and are
interested
and care about what you've presented in
fact not getting questions is worse than
get been
it's so much worse because that means
people probably fell asleep
or they just want to get to lunch
so it's actually and again if someone
finds an error in her work
first of all that's good second you want
it to happen there
yes
sure
people who are actually your local
colleagues right and not out in that
so i take it there isn't a bouncer at
the lecture halls that like ejects
people who are asking too many questions
yeah it should be
no one that
that will protect you you know
and i and i certainly felt it felt like
a verbal assault when i was new when i
was you know when i didn't when i wasn't
able to see the other side of it right
so i remember talking to a professor
um later about it and he was like you
know take a moment take a breath when
someone asks a question take a breath
let it land
and then if you have information if you
have something to contribute say you
know say it if you don't say i don't
know i can look that up and get back to
you
end of story like it didn't have to be
the big deal that it was in my head
right um and
so now
so many years after that what i can say
is this my acting background absolutely
does not only contribute but it it makes
me such a much better scientist than i
would have been without it
because not only can i
communicate
the significance of my research results
and i can do it in ways that people who
are not scientists would understand
without talking down to them
without assuming they know things that
they may not have decided to learn yet
i know how to do that because of the
acting background and i also know how to
network because that's all that acting
is like you have to like introduce
yourself at parties and like i knew how
to be a marketer and as a scientist you
actually are a business person you gotta
market yourself you gotta get out and
shake it so to speak and um to get that
next job or that next
you know that so wait neil collections
neil are you inspired at all to get an
mfa in acting hearing all of this well
so here's what happened i've been asked
on occasion to give like cameo
appearances and like i'm actually i'm in
six is it six five or six
feature length films in very small cameo
roles playing myself or someone
very
approximating myself and if you look at
the early ones uh
i suck it was like there's this gap
between my first couple appearances and
the next time because people said we're
not invited back at all so but but this
side of baptism rather than a formal
training i think i've gotten better at
this over the years and i have to agree
with omawa it's it is definitely infuses
every aspect of how you interact with
people and how you communicate your
facial expressions your body language
your your gestures how you're thinking
about how the person is thinking about
what you're saying all that an actor has
to think about when they're performing
and so yes i i have to agree but omawa
has has got it
the formal training where she can dig
deep into that far deeper than any place
i ever have to go
uh in my own profile
but let me add something uh because the
question uh started off mentioning alan
alda i don't know how many people know
but alan alda used to host scientific
american presents
it was i might have been science channel
or discovery channel and so he was he
liked science and he's always liked
science and he would walk into a lab and
be just like a regular person asking
blunt questions and he noticed that
scientists had a hard time figuring out
how to communicate back with him and he
said he wants to change that and so he
co-founded an entire school
at
the
state university of new york stony brook
on long island where their their whole
purpose
is to train
professors and graduate students how to
communicate the science that is their
profession
and
uh but uh
omar was like doing this from scratch
and so you're the og and
well i love i love his center i've
spoken with um
with people at his center i love the
what they're dedicated to um it's very
close to my heart
and it's you know
there's a course that i teach now here
at uc irvine that's
communication skills for physicists and
astronomers and it's you know not just
how to put a talk together but how to
deliver that talk to a broad range of
audiences and the same thing like neil
was saying it you have to
when you give a science talk
there's an objective just like an actor
in a scene on stage or in a movie
and it's not just say the lines the
objective might be
you know to get the person to give me
the money to
get all the way to the other side of the
bridge like you have in an acting school
we learn you have to have an objective
with every scene it's the same thing as
a scientist what do i want to do in this
talk do i want to inspire do i want it
um wait
are you saying it's real when actors say
what's my motivation that's a real thing
i didn't want to believe that was a real
thing but you're telling me that's a
real thing
meanwhile you asked
you asked moa what's your motivation at
any point and she's just gonna say smog
you know that's right
that was what motivated the whole thing
the motivation
let's go to get another question let's
get it okay so we have actually zeke
majed brad winter and chase kymes from
uh patreon all asked about terraforming
um and so basically the question is like
how possible is terraforming with our
current technology do we have enough
public interest to actually pursue it i
love it what do you think go for it and
tell us what terraforming is first
well my understanding of terraforming is
the
the principle behind it is that we would
change
or we would be dedicated to
the action of of trying to change
a planet an existing planet's
environment atmosphere ecosystem to be
more um
uh
amenable to life as we would want it
um
so perhaps
creating an environment in the most
extreme case which i you know
out of a a mars or a venus you might
want to create an earth then how would
you go about doing that um and so that
you could create a planet where life
could actually
survive and thrive now the way you began
your answer there it sounds like this is
not in the near future
well
you begin to it's kind of we think it
could be like maybe this is what we
might think of doing that it sounds like
this is not around the corner
the tentativeness that you picked up in
my voice is more related to my to be
honest moral
stance on the concept of terraforming
than any sort of science well are you
all getting star trek honest the prime
directive do not interfere
with it's it's more of a it is more of a
should we than could we question for me
um and there are beyond star trek there
actually are other scientists lucian
welkowitz who has an excellent ted talk
about this this whole um question of
let's not use mars as a backup planet i
think that's
either the subtitle or the primary title
of her ted talk um this idea of yes
let's go explore let's go explore so
that we have environments as back up in
case we screw up the earth too badly to
be repaired
um is this like is this like a dog
peeing on all the trees that that are
out there
just the same thing
i feel like this is when i buy um a pair
of pants that
are like clearly two sizes too small and
i'm always like i'll get there you know
what i mean but i know i'm never really
gonna get there i just wasted money on a
pair of pants you know
it's wishful thinking but but what is
the morality if the there's okay wait so
let's unpack this
it's one thing to say
while you're making mars a backup plan
why don't you just tend to earth as we
should so that's one moral posture
another moral
another posture is
uh
these other planets they might have life
of their own and we're just taking over
but if you confirm that they don't have
life for their own what's your what's
your problem what you got any problem
you got a problem with that
interesting question
yeah if if the planet is sterile
then who cares if you pitch tenth there
yeah i'd have to think more about that
uh there is an entire planetary
protection department at places like the
jet propulsion laboratory nasa's jpl
that is devoted to this this like
that question of we make sure that we
don't
we don't bring life with us to some
place where we're looking for life and
think oh we found life but the life we
found was the life we brought with us
yeah yeah somebody sneezed on the
detector right right
and also if we got there to make sure
that you know that we're that our
detection equipment is um robust enough
to be able to pick up on the life that
we would imagine might be there but
here's the thing
how would we
how could we be sure
that a planet absolutely unequivocally
was completely sterile and had no life
or promise of life evolving on that
planet
such that we could then shape it and
mold it however we want oh so you could
just sterilize it yourself and then
that's how you yeah that's one way
and you know actually
i mean i i have people very close to me
feel quite differently about this my
husband and i have debates about this
all the time i think he would take that
stance of like yeah if there's not life
on there why but the thing is
life as we know it might be very
different from
other life life that doesn't have water
as its primary solvent everything on
earth everything from the tiniest
microbe to the largest elephant
everything requires water
i saw a cool comic where two aliens
crashed in the desert
and they're like crawling along the
dunes and they're saying ammonia
ammonia
[Laughter]
there could be some other
other kind of solvent that we would have
no
way of or had not even thought about
much less thought about enough to form
formulate a plan to create a detector
that might be able to pick up on that
in some way or as you know spectron
spectrometer or something um
so i i think okay so you're no fun you
just want to fix earth you know that's
not fun at all but i'd like to fix earth
and i'd like to explore for the sake of
exploring
not for the sake of
changing to fit our standards or what we
what we think we
would need
and our engineer just found the the talk
the ted talk is lucian walkowitz right
as you said and the actual title of the
talk is let's not use mars as a backup
planet and so yeah that's that is the
the name of the talk not even the
subtitle so there you have it uh [ __ ]
we got to take another break when we
come back to our third segment uh we
might have to go into a lightning round
so we can get more of those questions in
uh you're
watching or listening to star talk
cosmic queries and this is all about
search for life on exoplanets when we
return
star talk cosmic queries edition we're
talking about exoplanets and the
possibility of them harboring life with
one of the world's experts on that very
subject and it's omawa shields a moa
welcome to star talk and nagin of course
my co-host my guest co-host for this and
you've got all the questions with you
but before we go into that uh negan how
do people find you online oh my gosh you
can find me at negin farsad
n-e-g-i-n-f-a-r-s-a-d
and uh and
anything separating your first and last
name no just right through on instagram
on twitter on twitter
uh and oh oh the fun you will have uh
reading through my things
you'll be the judge
other than your website where you're
you're um
encouraging girls to rise up to their
fullest potential how else might we find
you on social media yes well you can uh
find my faculty website at just google
uci and my name you can put in my first
name only
yeah that's good that's that'll find you
anywhere in the world i bet that's right
okay and then i am
[Music]
yeah that's all so you can just drop
your drop shields who needs shields
we have we have like prince madonna
thought about it
again let's start doing with that's how
we'll do it with her okay okay and then
my twitter handle my twitter handle is
also my first name only at aomoa as it
should be okay so negine let's let's see
how many we can knock out in this third
and final segment all right here we go
by the way i think all these questions
we're now only taking questions from
patreon remember
from our patreon uh support
so
so if you want to be able to ask a
question you know jump on in join the
patreon
well michael mayne one of your members
asks is it sorry it is my understanding
that volatile magnetic fields of red
dwarf stars periodically cause a large
star solar flares which adversely affect
planets within the stars
goldilocks zone is it possible for life
to survive on these star-blasted worlds
um i didn't understand that question at
all
and i was going to say my response
take that omaha
what do you think of that because you're
studying low mass stars which are cool
and red and the they're very susceptible
to
to
flares and things so how do you get out
of that one i think we back into a
corner negan so let's see what happens
here
i feel it yeah this is a very popular
question that i get at science talks
which i now welcome instead of uh fear
as we talked about before
i love the questions and
yes so the one thing about
these low-mass stars these red
cool m dwarf or red dwarf stars um they
have a lot of advantages they're 70 of
all stars it's easier to detect planets
around these stars they live forever
like even forever forever compared to
regular stars um like trillions of
people
truly so no
no red dwarf stars have ever died
that's how long their lifetimes are
their lifetimes are longer than the
current age of the universe so no stars
no red dwarf stars have ever died
so it seems to me you could evolve some
bad ass creatures if you were around for
that long
right on a planet
yeah so that's the other another
advantage is that they would permit
long time scales for both planetary and
biological evolution
um
but when they have these long lifetimes
that means that this like so all stars
are really active when they're young
um
and think of this as like a terrible two
space for those who have kids i have a
daughter who's um three and a half and
like yeah her terrible twos phase is
still going on
terrible threes
but the the terrible two space for red
dwarf stars can last as long as a
billion years
hey that's that's some terrible twos
phase and during that time
the planets around these stars in this
so-called goldilocks zone habitable zone
that region around a star where a planet
could be not too hot or not too cold for
water to stay liquid on the surface
that's what we call the goldilocks zone
planets in that zone could be pelted by
all of this high-energy radiation during
this terrible jews phase this um and
that that could threaten the atmospheres
of these planets
it could threaten
biology we know that for example uv
radiation is harmful to biology that's
why we wear sunscreen
um but think of it as like uv radiation
on steroids
for life on a planet orbiting a red
dwarf star and that could be but i'll
save it so that could be bad for sure
and that's certainly one of the largest
disadvantages that people have brought
up for for life orbiting i feel a butt
coming okay
okay if you're
we know that there's tons of life in the
ocean so you could still have life
doing its thing and being nice and
sheltered from uv radiation if it was at
the bottom of the ocean or even just a
couple of hundred meters below the
surface
um
and
you know there's
that terrible two-space even though it
lasts as long as a billion years it
doesn't last forever and it could be
that atmospheres are thick enough for
example to withstand that radiation
and we've done some studies to show that
under certain circumstances you might
not for example deplete an entire ozone
layer by that high energy radiation
pelting the atmosphere you could still
have some left over
so it depends
is
the short answer okay
all right so it's not as bad as so
it is real that these are threats
but those threats
don't exhaust all possible ways you
could survive them
correct yeah okay all right
all right keep it going again all right
charles malouf asks if earth was about
to be destroyed and you had to board a
ship bound for another planet where you
would spend the rest of your life which
destination would you choose at the
ticket counter and you should assume
there's already a habitable facility
there and travel speed is a significant
percentage of c so you don't age much
from the journey
they got this all figured out huh sure
they sure do so
what is your favorite planet that's
really what that comes down to yes yes
it does
um i have a soft spot for a planet
called kepler-62f
and i say that wistfully because this
planet is 1200 light years away
um and so it's
very easy are you leaving the solar
system for this destination was that
allowed negan in this setup
we'd have to we'd have to we're going to
another oh you see i kept thinking
exoplanets but yeah cause then you have
exoplanets on the brain but that's okay
we'll take it
so it could be i guess yeah like within
our solar system like uh
yeah it's still a little give me give me
both answers so in the solar system what
would it be
um
well jupiter's moon europa is certainly
a place that everyone is excited about
and i've always loved because we are
fairly certain that there is an ocean
there except the ocean is below
potentially kilometers thick ice
um so a very very thick ice shell on top
and then
and then uh
[Music]
you're thinking about you're thinking
like a scientist all right you're saying
you go there because that'd be cool to
study it it sounds like he just said
where do you want to go to live yeah
where are we hanging out where are you
going to hang out where are you
brunching like what are you
yeah um
i always think about that on our planet
it's funny i
i
ever since i had a child it's like i
don't want i don't i wouldn't want to
leave like i wouldn't want to leave
bring your kids with you and then if you
can survive them saying are we there yet
you know then it'll be fun
i'm gonna choose i'm gonna choose
neptune because it's my daughter's
favorite planet and she she loves it
because it's
um
and we haven't talked about ammonia and
how that does that and all that but just
because it's blue and i think that would
be fun
um i would take any moon of saturn
because then you can look up and see
saturn in the nightstand oh yeah
that's gotta be beautiful so tell me
more about kepler-62l
kepler-62f is this
yes it's uh 1200 light years away it's
one of a five planet system orbiting
this this k star so a little bit a
little bit cooler than the sun
not as cool as a red dwarf star
and
it's really it's one of the first
planets that we were able to my team was
actually able to
look at how
the gravitational interactions
between this planet and and its siblings
so this planet is not alone in its
system it's got four other siblings that
are also revolt you know going around
kepler-62 it's it's parent star how
those interactions how they can push and
pull on each other and how that affects
the climate of this planet and that's
what i study is how
the climate of exoplanets um
is determined by
a myriad of factors
including how planets push and pull on
each other and so okay so you're biased
because like you studied the damn thing
this is like i didn't take ownership
you've already planted the flag the
al-moawa shields plan
okay there you go yeah and so i'd love
to be able to go and see
and test some of the theories and
predictions we made
on this planet all right all right
again thinking like a scientist not just
hanging out on a beach how much would
you ate i know because that's all i'm
thinking about
how much would you age though going to
that planet to that exo planet
i mean it we're assuming this question
said a few percentage a few percent of
the speed of light i mean if we if we
were somehow able to
attain light speed
um it would still take us 1200 years to
get there
and 1200 years to get back
um but wait you wouldn't age but we'd
all be long dead and all you everyone
would have forgotten about you if you
come back
so just go and just don't come back and
you're you're cool you're fine
so
here we go chas uh jen corelli says when
looking for other habitable planets do
we also look for signs of other life
that's not carbon based i know silicon
based life has been talked about but
curious of the signs of other base life
is easy to scope out i love this
question because i'm always like are you
looking for carbon and then also like
gummy bears and also like what i mean
what is the list of the things that
you're looking for you know yeah we and
how biased are we in this in the in
these criteria
we're very biased i mean our our n if in
scientific parlance are n is one meaning
we have one example of a planet that we
know is habitable
earth that's it and so we're
we're using everything we know life
needs on earth as our metric for
where else to look for life what to look
for on those planets um
and this is where the water bias comes
in right because we all need water
and you say well we need water so
clearly everybody else needs water
yeah and there's three things there's
three fundamental requirements that
we've identified that life needs on
earth and it's liquid water
it's an energy source and in some cases
that's the sun
in other cases it might be
um
just chemicals for life that's
underneath at the bottom of the ocean
and doesn't have access to to sunlight
so stellar or chemical energy
and some sort of environment to form
complex organic molecules from like
elements essential to biology like
sulfur and phosphorus and oxygen and
nitrogen carbon so that environment
would have to be like the right
temperature and the right pressure to
sustain big molecules to experiment and
make some anything complex
this is why water
is the most
critical
of those three because
a terrestrial planet by nature has some
kind of energy source and the basic
building blocks in some form that are
needed for life but what isn't as common
as liquid water and you can see that
really in our own solar system
um
and
that's what we know
all life on earth needs
is liquid water and so
we we use that as our
you know as our criterion but as this
question points out it is limiting
um because there might be other ways and
there are astrobiologists
and an astrobiologist is someone it
could be an astronomer but it could also
be an oceanographer it could be a
geologist
astrobiologists are very
interdisciplinary they're using their
primary field of expertise to address
questions related to
the life elsewhere
to answer the question of how you know
how are we alone
um what's the origin evolution
distribution and future of life in the
universe so negan i want to find a
planet that doesn't depend on water that
that it depends on wine
that would be interesting
yeah
and grapes are a big industry there
no actually wine is mostly water of
course so i i i kid i can't so we gotta
go it's serious uh lightning round now
so uh omawa you've got to answer
questions in one word or one sentence at
most oh my gosh
no yes no um okay uh heidi wagamons
asked are we able to get to other
habitable planets if the universe
expands so fast by the way from the
um heidi is from the netherlands oh cool
um
yes the universe is expanding um
however we
especially because of recent recent
times we now have a new mission a
relatively new mission called the
transiting exoplanet survey satellite we
call it tess for short it's the
successor to nasa's kepler mission which
stared at one patch of sky for about 10
years and just kept taking pictures
looking for planets that passed in front
of their host star from our viewing
angle and
we actually looked we saw little dips in
the light of the star when the planet
passed in front of those stars so tess
is actually an all sky survey and it's
looking at
stars in the nearby solar neighborhood
so because of that we're finding a lot
more
a lot more planets first off around
these cool small red stars because
they're the most
abundant stars in the solar neighborhood
anyway
and those planets
are much closer to us they're going to
be easier to follow up on to look at
with next generation telescopes and
hopefully one day to try to journey to
okay that wasn't a one word or one
sentence
i couldn't figure out how else to do it
also by the expansion of the universe
our galaxy will hang tight for a while
even in the expanding universe so i
think we're okay and it's great to hear
that we're discovering many more that
are nearby in case we're going to make
that escape list
keep the beach destinations in mind when
you're putting together that list you
guys
okay let's get one more one more we have
from ashley kosdorf um
floridian i've been wondering what a
black hole does for the universe from a
circle of life aspect most things on
earth are recycled however black holes
seem to only consume they're not yeah
black holes aren't recycling what's up
with that
are they are they the like the landfill
of the sky or what did i is that
accurate
that is so funny i just watched i was
just watching um loki
the uh the marvel show loki the other
day and there's lucky stores brother or
something thor's brother yeah the god of
mischief um but he's sort of taking a
moral turn in this i won't give it away
um but there's this whole notion of like
what comes after and and this creature
that this void that kind of consumes all
matter and um
i mean i think the answer
my i guess it's my three word answer
would be i don't know and i believe we
don't know um
right so the two i don't knows that a
scientist can utter one of them is they
don't know and the other i don't know is
no one knows because we don't have the
answer yet at all no matter who you ask
so but i love how like basically this
was a real this is really judgmental
towards black holes
you know and we haven't i haven't heard
very many uh approaches to black holes
that are like you know they just consume
consume they don't care about anybody
else you know well i think so here's the
issue here's how selfish black holes
selfish black holes here's how they win
the day the reason why we recycle is
because we don't want what we just use
to to
litter the environment
that's the only motivation to recycle
as in addition to whether the material
is is
is renewable right but that's why if
it's if it's not renewable
you get to use it again and
there you don't and
you don't discard it on the on the on on
the shoreline a black hole
eats it you will never find it on
anybody's shore
after that you won't find it anywhere
it's not in landfill you're right and
again it is its own landfill yeah
but it's
smells don't come out it's not unsightly
it's not a not in my backyard thing in
fact everyone should have a black hole
in their backyard
well and there's a black hole at the
center of every galaxy right
so maybe that's that's it
oh moa here's what we do so when we have
galactic federations
that's the garbage chute
for all the trash that we collect in the
galaxy i like it can i also just say we
don't know that if in black holes there
isn't like a giant etsy shop that's
selling
repurposed
repurposed from stars
handbags okay
[Laughter]
actually some models for the interior
black holes have them open up an entire
other space-time continuum so that in
fact things that fall through intact
could emerge on the other side separate
from our universe uh entering a whole
other universe created by the black hole
itself
and i'm surprised
there's not as much science fiction that
has exploited that understanding of
black holes as i think should
but
anyhow yeah guys we got to call it quits
there
i i omaha this you you've been away too
long okay and delighted to have you uh
this is a very popular topic and and we
have a lot of interest deep interest in
this and maybe we can get you back on
and continue it or especially when when
tests uh is tests
what's the status of tests right now
tess is flying and they've actually
found many potentially habitable planets
now so maybe we can get sort of an
update on tests
yeah because we didn't specifically talk
about tests in this episode but uh
transiting explorer survey telescope
transiting exoplanet survey satellite
exoplanet survey satellite um and
i think we'd welcome just an update on
what some of the findings are from that
next generation of our search for
exoplanets
so
oh moa thank you for being on star talk
thank you for having me everybody all
right and nagin always good to have you
oh my god thanks so much for having me i
learned something today
okay that that's what this is about so
but you said it as though those are like
real jerk-offs
but again the way you said that so other
times i did this i didn't learn a damn
thing
that was kind of you cop the attitude
there admit it
omar really used her skills on me i i
really you know i really felt like i got
something all right that's how that's
how we roll so this has been star talk
cosmic queries neil degrasse tyson your
personal astrophysicist as always i bid
you
to keep looking up
[Music]